This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. From high school corridors to the corridors of power, human beings are always trying to influence one another. We try to convince others to like the books and music we love. We want colleagues to follow our suggestions on changes at work. We lobby friends and family to support the political parties we endorse. But have you ever noticed, some people are more effective at persuasion than others. They convince others to go along with their ideas, to agree with them.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。从高中的走廊到权力的殿堂，人类总是在试图相互影响。我们试图说服别人喜欢我们挚爱的书籍和音乐。我们希望同事在工作变革中听从我们的建议。我们游说朋友和家人支持我们赞同的政党。但你有没有发现，有些人比其他人更擅长说服。他们说服别人顺从他们的想法，同意他们的观点。
These people are better at sales, better at winning elections, maybe even better at scoring dates. What explains this? Charisma, Charm, Goodlux? Today, we launched the first of a two-part mini-series that examines the science of influence. Insights from the world of persuasion this week on Hidden Brain. Robert Chaldeini grew up in Milwaukee in the 1950s. From an early age, he was an observer
这些人更擅长销售，更擅长赢得选举，甚至可能更擅长约会。这该如何解释？是个人魅力、迷人特质，还是长相出众？今天，我们推出了探讨影响力科学的两部分迷你系列的开篇之作。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将带您领略说服世界的深刻见解。罗伯特·恰尔迪尼在20世纪50年代的密尔沃基长大。从小到大，他就是一个
of human nature. I grew up in an entirely Italian family, in a predominantly Polish neighborhood, in a historically German city, in an otherwise rural state. And what happened to me in my thinking fairly early on was to recognize the norms associated with each of those subcultures was different enough to make it more likely that somebody would say yes to you if you understood what those norms and factors were that described how people were to behave in each of those situations. What were family dinners like at your dining table and at the dining table of your Polish friends? Very different. So that in an Italian home, it was not uncommon at all for us to have arguments at the table for us to disagree and to speak with our hands about it and
人类行为的观察者。我是在一个完全的意大利家庭中长大的，周围主要是一个波兰人社区，在一个历史上属于德国人的城市里，在一个原本属于乡村的州。我早期在思考中发生的变化是，我认识到与其中每一个亚文化相关的规范是足够不同的，如果你了解那些描述人们在每种情况下应该如何行事的规范和因素，那么别人更有可能对你说“好的”。你们餐桌上的家庭晚餐和你们波兰朋友的餐桌有什么不同？非常不同。因此，在一个意大利家庭里，我们在餐桌上争论、意见不合并且用手势表达，这可以说是司空见惯的事情，
were one person to challenge another. When I went to have dinner with one of my um, playmates soon, no, it was much more organized, much much more uh, genteel and people uh, accorded each other a kind of grace that we didn't uh, in my family, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, something he wanted when he demanded it. But if he was interacting with strangers or acquaintances, he needed a different approach. By the time I was in Anna-Lessent, I recognized if I drove out of the city and let's say I wanted to buy some apples by somebody a farmer at the side of the road with a stand, the interaction that I would have with that farmer had to be preceded by some sort of sociable exchange. We had to be connected in a way.
一个人挑战另当我很快去其中一个玩伴家里吃晚餐时，不，那里要更有条理得多，非常非常温文尔雅，人们彼此给予一种我家人所没有的优雅……他要求得到某样东西时，只要一提出要求就能如愿以偿。但如果他是与陌生人或熟人交往，他就需要一种不同的方法。当我还处于青少年时期时，我就认识到，如果我开车出城，比方说我想在路边一个摊位向某个农民买几个苹果，我与那个农民之间的互动必须以某种社交交流作为前置条件。我们需要以某种方式建立联系。
Maybe I would talk about the score of the last baseball game, and then I would get better prices. In this rural communal environment it was important to establish a commonality and a sense of membership, shared membership in this category. When Bob went off to college, he continued to observe people. He noticed some people had a knack for getting others to go along with them. He didn't have theories that connected all these observations, but he could just see that some ways of talking was simply more effective than others.
也许我会谈论上一场棒球比赛的比分，然后我就能拿到更好的价格。在这个乡村集体环境中，建立共同性和归属感、在这个范畴内的共享归属感是很重要的。当鲍勃去上大学时，他继续观察人们。他注意到有些人有一种让其他人听从自己的诀窍。他当时并没有把所有这些观察联系起来的理论，但他能看出，某些说话方式确实比其他方式更有效。
You know, I would say that all my life, I was a patsy. I was an easy mark for the pitches of salespeople, fundraisers who would come to my door and so on. But I don't remember them as frauds. I remember them as individuals who were able to move me to change my choices based on what they were providing in terms of information or enticements. One day in college, Bob was in his dorm room when there was a knock at the door. So it was somebody selling subscriptions to magazines and I was a student, I didn't have a lot of money, but I was a sports fan, and he offered me a subscription to sports illustrated. And I was going to say no, because I didn't have the funds really. And he said, it's the most popular subscription here in your dorm. And the experts rated as the number one sports magazine in the United States. And I found myself
你知道，我可以说我一辈子都是个易受骗的人。我对销售人员、上门募捐者的推销等等毫无抵抗力。但我不认为他们是骗子。我认为他们是能够根据他们提供的信息或诱惑，促使我改变选择的个人。在大学的一天，鲍勃正在宿舍里，突然有人敲门。原来是一个推销杂志订阅的人，而我当时是个学生，没有太多钱，但我是个体育迷，他向我推销《体育画报》的订阅。我本来打算拒绝，因为我实在没有资金。他说：“这是你们宿舍最受欢迎的订阅。”专家们将其评为全美第一大体育杂志。然后我发现自己
buying that subscription. I didn't want it, but he had arranged for me to choose something I didn't want because of what he said to me. And did you ponder afterwards what he had said, did you ask yourself afterwards, what exactly happened in that conversation to get him to change my mind? Did that question go through your head? It did, but I don't know I had the terms to explain it, but I knew that they had worked and I knew that he had turned a note to a yes. So there was something powerful there inside what he had said. Bob wanted to discover what that power was. It was clear that lots of things didn't work to persuade others. Some things simply turned people into brick walls.
买下了那个订阅。我并不想要它，但他通过对我说的话，安排我选择了我并不想要的东西。事后你有没有琢磨过他说的话？事后你有没有问过自己，那次对话中到底发生了什么，才让他改变了我的主意？这个问题有没有在你的脑海里闪过？闪过，但我不知道我当时是否有术语来解释它，但我知道它们起作用了，我知道他把一个“不”字变成了“行”。所以他所说的话里面蕴含着某种强大的力量。鲍勃想要找出那种力量是什么。很明显，很多东西在说服别人时是没用的。有些东西只会把人变成铜墙铁壁。
You got a lot of nose and you got them fast. But other approaches seemed to work like magic. It was like a key turning in a lock. As Bob embarked on his career in psychology, he decided he wanted to understand how those locks and keys really worked. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantanta. There are different ways to be a psychologist. You can run experiments in a lab or survey people on the street. But as Bob Chaldeenie set out to discover the keys to influence and persuasion, he decided
你会得到很多“不”，而且速度极快。但其他方法似乎像魔术一样奏效。就像一把钥匙转动了一把锁。当鲍勃开始他的心理学职业生涯时，他决定要弄清楚那些锁和钥匙到底是怎样运作的。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。成为一名心理学家有不同的方法。你可以在实验室里做实验，或者在街上调查人们。但正当鲍勃·恰尔迪尼着手寻找影响力和说服力的关键时，他决定
to follow the instincts of his childhood. He decided the best way to understand how influence worked was to closely observe people who were very successful at influencing others. I decided to determine what were the most powerful effects on the influence process by studying the practitioners whose economic livelihood depends on the strength of the strategies they employ and the effects that they produce.
遵循他童年的直觉。他认为理解影响力如何运作的最佳方法，是密切观察那些在影响他人方面非常成功的人。我决定通过研究那些经济生计取决于他们采用的策略的强度以及他们所产生效果的从业人员，来确定对影响力过程最强大的影响是什么。
Someone telling you about how influence worked didn't have skin in the game, but if you were a salesperson whose effectiveness as an influencer determined how much you got paid, maybe even whether you got paid, you had to quickly learn what worked and what didn't work. I answered ads in the newspaper for trainees. So I learned how to sell nutritional supplements door to door. I learned how to sell automobiles from a lot. Wherever people were asking for recruits for their organization, I would answer the ad, and I would do so in Cognito. Disguised identity, disguised intent, I worked under cover to learn what they had learned were the most powerful influences on the influence process. And I did so not just in sales, I also looked at fundraising, I looked at
一个向你讲述影响力如何运作的人并没有切身利益，但如果你是一个销售人员，你作为影响者的有效性决定了你的收入多少，甚至决定了你是否能拿到报酬，你就必须快速了解什么有用，什么没用。我回复了报纸上的招聘广告。于是我学会了如何挨家挨户推销营养补充剂。我学会了如何在停车场卖汽车。无论哪里有人为他们的组织招募新人，我都会回复广告，而且我会匿名前往。隐藏身份，隐藏意图，我卧底去了解他们所学到的对影响力过程最强大的影响是什么。我不只是在销售领域这样做，我还研究了筹款，我研究了
recruiting and procurement, these kinds of jobs where your responsibility is to influence the situation for the best possible outcomes. And I tried to look for commonalities across these various professions. Which were the approaches, tactics, principles that were employed in common? Because that would tell me which were the most likely to be features of the human condition. And what shocked me was how small the footprint was of those principles that were in common across all of those settings and professions.
招聘和采购，这类工作的责任是影响局势以获得最佳可能的结果。我试图寻找这些不同职业之间的共性。有哪些共同采用的方法、战术和原则？因为这会告诉哪些最可能是人类生存状况的特征。而让我震惊的是，在所有这些环境和职业中通用的那些原则，其影响范围竟然如此之小。
I only counted six. I understand that at one point you actually learned how to sell portrait photography. Tell me about that experience. What was that like? What did you learn about what they did? So first of all we would sell on the phone but we also had certain kinds of experiences in retail establishments you you go to a Walmart or a target and so on and there will be a booth of people selling portrait photography for your family, right and you could get these Photographs and then there were a number of options that you had for how many photographs
我只数出了六个。我了解到，你曾在某个时候真正学会了如何推销肖像摄影。跟我讲讲那段经历。那是什么样的？你对他们的做法有什么了解？首先，我们会在电话里销售，但我们在零售场所也有某些类型的经历，比如你去沃尔玛或塔吉特等等，那里会有一个展位，有人在为你的家庭推销肖像摄影，对吧，你可以买到这些照片，然后你可以对照片的数量做出各种选择
of what size and so on, and you could get different sets. And of course, they varied by price. And what we were told to do when a family would only chose to purchase a small number of these photographs. They told us to say this to the family. Well, you know, because of stocking constraints, we'll be only able to keep the pictures of your children for one week. After that, we'll be forced to burn the pictures of your children. You could see the look on the faces of the parent,
尺寸等等，你可以买到不同的组合。当然，它们的价格各异。当一个家庭只选择购买其中少量的照片时，我们被告知要这样做。我们被告知要对这个家庭说：“嗯，你知道，由于库存限制，我们只能把你们孩子的照片保留一周。之后，我们将被迫烧掉你们孩子的照片。”你可以看到父母脸上的表情，
where you're going to burn, the images of my children. So it was essentially something that appealed to the idea of scarcity. This is going to be gone. It's going to be gone within seven days unless you choose to curtail that loss. After about two and a half years, Bob started analyzing the data he had collected. At his lab at Arizona State University, he used experimental methods to study the practices of the salespeople he had observed. Several patterns emerged, techniques of persuasion that almost every influence professional used.
你们要烧掉我孩子的照片？所以这本质上是一种诉诸稀缺性概念的方法。这东西要没了。如果不选择止损，它将在七天内消失。大约两年半后，鲍勃开始分析他收集的数据。他在亚利桑那州立大学的实验室里，用实验方法研究了他所观察到的销售人员的做法。几个模式浮现出来，几乎每个影响力专业人士都在使用的说服技巧。
The first technique was the one used by those portrait photography salespeople. People want more of what they can have less of. What we mean by scarcity is entities or opportunities that are unique, are uncommon, or are dwindling in availability. When that's the case, we want those things more because of the desire to have those things that we are missing, that we will forego unless we seize them. I'm convinced that a major factor that lends itself to the power of scarcity is loss aversion. Loss is the ultimate form of scarcity. If you can't have it, it's gone.
第一种技巧正是那些肖像摄影推销人员所使用的。人们想要更多他们能得到更少的东西。我们所说的稀缺性，是指独特、不常见或可用性正在减少的实体或机会。在这种情况下，我们会更想要这些东西，因为我们渴望拥有那些我们正在失去的东西，如果我们不抓住它们，就会错失它们。我确信，赋予稀缺性力量的一个主要因素是损失厌恶。损失是稀缺性的最终形式。如果你无法拥有它，它就彻底消失了。
So because of loss aversion which I think is deeply installed in us, things that are scarce, dwindling in availability that we will otherwise, go or miss become very attractive. I was trying to book an airline ticket the other day and I put in my dates and I was just scouting around to try and see if I wanted to make the trip. But when I put in my dates, the website told me that the tickets were available and this was the price, but they had a little line in italics at the bottom saying only two seats available at this price. Is that scarcity? That is.
因此，由于我认为深深植根于我们之中的损失厌恶，那些稀缺的、可用性正在减少的、否则我们就会放弃或错失的东西，变得极具吸引力。前几天我正试图预订一张机票，我输入了日期，只是到处看看以决定是否要进行这次旅行。但当我输入日期时，网站告诉我机票有售，这就是价格，但它们在底部用斜体字写着一小行字：此价格仅剩两座。这算稀缺吗？算。
It says dwindling availability, you are risking the loss of this price. There is a company called Booking.com that does reservations for hotels and flights around it. And they were using my principles and they hit upon this particular tactic where you'll look at a hotel room online. It will be a certain price and they will say two things. They'll say only two of these left at this price. And there are five people looking at this room right now. It's competition for scarce resources. The first time they did that, they're marketing people, sent a message to the technology people and said, there's something wrong because we're getting flooded with so many purchases, there's something wrong with our system. And the technology people said, no, there's nothing
它表明可用性正在减少，你面临着失去这个价格的风险。有一家名为Booking.com的公司，专门预订酒店和航班。他们正在运用我的原则，并且偶然想出了这个特定的策略：当你在线查看一个酒店房间时，它会有一个特定的价格，他们会说两件事。他们会说这个价格只剩两间了。现在有五个人正在看这个房间。这是对稀缺资源的竞争。他们第一次这样做时，营销人员给技术人员发了一条消息，说出问题了，因为我们收到了太多的购买请求，我们的系统出毛病了。而技术人员说，不，系统没出问题。
wrong with the system. It's what you said that caused people to leap, to avoid missing out on this favorable opportunity. One inside Bob had, as he studied the science of persuasion and influence, was that effective techniques were often effective, even when you knew exactly how they worked and why they affected you. Bob eventually became one of the world's foremost experts on the signs of influence, but he still found himself susceptible to the techniques he studied. Like the time he read an announcement about a local Mormon temple. So I live in the Phoenix Arizona area, there's a suburb called Mesa, and there's a very impressive Mormon temple in the center of Mesa, where non-members are not allowed to visit a certain section of the temple that
是你们说的话导致人们蜂拥而至，以避免错过这个有利的机会。鲍勃在研究说服力和影响力科学时得出的一个内部见解是，即使你确切知道这些技巧是如何运作的以及它们为什么会影响你，有效的技巧通常仍然有效。鲍勃最终成为世界领先的影响力科学专家之一，但他发现自己仍然容易受到他所研究的技巧的影响。就像有一次他读到一则关于当地摩门教圣殿的公告。我住在亚利桑那州凤凰城地区，有一个叫梅萨的郊区，在梅萨的中心有一个非常宏伟的摩门教圣殿，非成员不允许参观圣殿的某个特定区域，
is exclusive to members. Except in the first few weeks after a temple is constructed, then anyone is allowed to see all of it, or after a significant enough renovation that the temple is seen to be a new one. And I remember reading an account that the Mormon temple in Mesa was now going to be available for me to visit even that sacrosanct area that is normally exclusive to members. And I remember calling a colleague of mine and saying, Gus, it's available. How about if we go over there? And he said, Bob, what is it about more the morning temperature? Is it are you especially
该区域是成员专用的。除非是在圣殿建成后的头几周，那时任何人都可以参观全部内容，或者在经过足够重大修缮、使圣殿被视为一座新圣殿之后。我记得曾读到过一篇报道，梅萨的摩门教圣殿现在对我开放参观了，甚至包括那个通常只有成员才能进入的神圣区域。我记得我给一位同事打了个电话说：“加斯，它开放了。我们去那儿看看怎么样？”他说：“鲍勃，关于这个摩门圣殿是怎么回事？你对
interested in church architecture? Are you especially interested in the morning? I said, no, none of those. It's because I can't have it. If I don't go now, I'll never be able to hand it. And it occurred to me, then, what I've just seen is the effect of scarcity on my choices that was independent of the merits of what I was getting. I didn't care about what was in that sector. I only cared that I couldn't get there before and now I can. Crystalized scarcity. We can all think of ways we respond to scarcity in our own lives.
教堂建筑特别感兴趣吗？你对摩门教特别感兴趣吗？”我说：“不，都不是。是因为我得不到它。如果我现在不去，我将永远无法接触到它。”然后我突然意识到，我刚刚看到的是稀缺性对我选择的影响，这与我所获得的事物的价值本身无关。我不在乎那个区域里有什么。我只在乎我以前去不了，而现在我可以了。强烈的稀缺性。我们都能想到在自己的生活中对稀缺性做出反应的方式。
There are also ways to experimentally measure this phenomenon. At Florida State University, students were asked to rate the quality of cafeteria food. Some time later, they were asked to do it again. The second evaluations were far more glowing than the first. Why? There was no difference in the merits of the food, right? They didn't buy more high quality food or higher-end new chef. It was that because of a fire, they weren't allowed in the cafeteria for the next two weeks. And so now what they couldn't have
也有通过实验来衡量这种现象的方法。在佛罗里达州立大学，学生们被要求评价食堂食物的质量。一段时间后，他们被要求再次评价。第二次的评价比第一次要热情得多。为什么？食物的品质没有任何区别，对吧？他们并没有购买更高品质的食物或更高档的新主厨。原因在于一场火灾，导致他们在接下来的两周内不准进入食堂。所以现在那些他们得不到的东西
became more valuable in terms of its appeal. As we will explore in different ways in this episode and the next, there are ways to use techniques of influence ethically and ways to use these techniques unethically. One domain where influencers regularly use scarcity is in sales and marketing. Bob says there is a way to do this right and a way to do it wrong. I was in a appliance store, I wasn't looking for a television set but I saw one at a sale price and I knew that this set was highly rated in consumer reports and so I was standing in front of it. There was a brochure on the counter. I was looking through the brochure and the salesperson
在吸引力方面变得更有价值了。正如我们将在本集和下一集以不同方式探讨的那样，有合乎道德地使用影响力技巧的方法，也有不道德地使用这些技巧的方法。影响者经常使用稀缺性的一个领域是销售和营销。鲍勃说，有一种正确的方法，也有有一种错误的方法。我在一家电器店，我本没打算买电视，但我看到一台电视在打折，我知道这台电视在《消费者报告》中评价很高，所以我站在它前面。柜台上有一本宣传册。我正在翻看宣传册时，销售人员
approached. He said, I see you're interested in this set at this price. I can see why. This is a great deal, but I have to tell you, it's our last one." And then he said, I just got a call from a woman who said she might come by this afternoon to buy it. Shankar, I'm supposed to be the guru of influence. Twenty minutes later, I'm wheeling out of the shop with that set in my cart. And it occurred to me that there was something crucial about the ethics of that man's assertion. If he was right, I wanted him to give me scarcity information. I wanted that information to help me decide what to do. If he hadn't done that, and I went home To think it over and then came back the next day, and it was gone. I would have said to him
走近了。他说：“我看到你对这台特价电视感兴趣。我能理解为什么。这是一笔划算的买卖，但我必须告诉你，这是我们最后一台了。”然后他说：“我刚刚接到一个女人的电话，她说她今天下午可能会顺便过来买下它。”香卡，我本该是影响力大师。二十分钟后，我推着购物车把那台电视推出了店门。我突然意识到，那个男人言论的道德规范中有些至关重要的事情。如果他是对的，我希望他提供给我稀缺性信息。我希望这些信息能够帮助我决定该怎么做。如果他没有这样做，而我回家去
What? You didn't tell me it was The last one. What's wrong with you, man? That's the information I want to have in order to make a good decision. Right? So, if, however, that was a hardifice, that was a device he was using, because in fact, there are retail outlets that have been indicted for using that strategy. They train their salespeople to say, this is the last one. They're plenty in the back room when they just go and fill that spot with a new one. So I went back the next morning, after I had purchased this, was there an empty spot on the shelf?
仔细想想，然后第二天回来，它却卖光了。我会对他说：“什么？你没告诉我那是最后一台吗？老兄，你脑子有毛病吗？”这就是为了做出明智决定，我想要拥有的信息。对吧？所以，如果那是一个借口，是他使用的一个手段，因为事实上，确实有零售店因使用这种策略而被起诉。他们训练销售人员说：“这是最后一台了。”而后方储藏室里其实还堆满了货物，他们只是走过去用一台新的把那个空位填满。所以我第二天早上买完后又回去了，货架上有空位吗？
There was. He was honest. What I did was to go back to my office and write a very positive review of that store and that salesperson. If there had been another one on that shelf and I had seen that it was a trick, I would have written a very poor review of that shop because I think it's very important for us to penalize the people who use these strategies dishonestly, who reduce their value to us, their predictive value, their diagnostic value, in our choices. We have to penalize those people who deceive us by using one or another of the principles of influence.
有的。他是诚实的。我所做的是回到办公室，对那家店和那个销售人员写了一篇非常积极的评价。如果货架上还有另一台，而我发现这是一个骗局，我会对那家店写一篇非常差的评价，因为我认为对我们来说，惩罚那些不诚实使用这些策略的人是非常重要的，他们降低了这些策略对我们的价值，降低了它们在我们选择过程中的预测价值和诊断价值。我们必须惩罚那些利用某种影响力原则来欺骗我们的人。
And we have to command, we have to praise those people who do so honestly. All of us have also seen the power of a second form of influence. When someone gives you a gift for your birthday, you feel like giving them a gift when their birthday rolls run. If you get invited to a friend's home for dinner, it's only a matter of time before you invite them over to your place. When we obtain favors, we feel the need to return favors. It's the rule in every human society that says we are obligated to give back to others who have first given to us. We say yes to those we owe. The reason that's the case in every human
我们必须表扬那些诚实运用这些原则的人。我们所有人都见过第二种形式的影响力的力量。当有人在你的生日送你礼物时，当他们的生日到来时，你会觉得有必要回赠他们礼物。如果你应邀去朋友家吃晚餐，那么迟早你也会邀请他们到你家做客。当我们获得恩惠时，我们会觉得有必要回报恩惠。这是整个人类社会都存在的规则，它表明我们有义务回馈那些首先给予我们帮助的人。我们对那些我们亏欠的人说“好”。每个人类社会之所以会出现这种情况，
society is, first of all, that we have very nasty names for people who don't play by that rule, who take without giving in return. In English, we call them moochers or takers or ingrates or teenagers, actually. Nobody wants to be labeled like that. So we go to great lengths to be sure that we are seen as someone who pays our debts, who gives back to those who give to us. It's not what we have received. It's that we have received. That spurs us into action. I mean, I had a similar situation a while ago, when I was approached by a Boy Scout on a city street.
首先是因为我们对那些不遵守这一规则、只索取不回报的人有非常难听的称呼。在英语中，我们称他们为白吃白喝者、索取者、忘恩负义者，实际上还有青少年。没有人愿意被贴上这样的标签。因此，我们会竭尽全力确保自己被视为一个偿还债务、回报那些给予我们帮助的人的人。不是因为我们收到了什么。而是因为我们收到了。这促使我们采取行动。我的意思是，不久前我也遇到过类似的情况，当时我在一条城市街道上被一名童子军接近。
He wanted me to buy a couple of his tickets to the Boy Scout circus that Saturday. And I declined. They were $5 a piece in those days. I declined. And he said, Oh, well, if you can't do that, would you want to buy a couple of our chocolate bars here? There are only one dollar a piece.
他想让我买几张他那个星期六童子军马戏团的门票。我拒绝了。那时候门票是5美元一张。我拒绝了。他说：“哦，好吧，如果你不能买那个，你想买几块我们的巧克力棒吗？只要一美元一块。”
And I bought his chocolate bars. And I realized that something important had happened because I don't like chocolate. But I like dollars and he was walking away with two of my dollars and I was standing there with two of his chocolate bars. So what happened there was a different form of reciprocation. It was a reciprocation of concessions, which also plays a big role in human culture. If I make a concession to you, there is an obligation to meet me and make a concession and return in any kind of an exchange. And so that's what the boy's cut did.
我买了他的巧克力棒。我意识到发生了一件重要的事情，因为我不喜欢巧克力。但我喜欢美元，他拿着我的两美元走开了，而我手里拿着他的两块巧克力棒。所以那里发生的是另一种形式的互惠。那是让步的互惠，它在人类文化中也扮演着重要角色。如果我对你做出让步，在任何形式的交换中，都有义务去回应我并做出相应的让步。这就是那个童子军所做的。
He made a concession from $5 a piece to $1. And I said yes, and it didn't matter that I didn't want what he was offering for $1. I wanted to be true to the rule. So this technique is sometimes called rejection and then retreat. Unpack that for me, Bob. What's happening here? So the strategy is to ask for a large enough favor that people will most likely say no to it. And then the influence agent retreats to a smaller favor and the subject of this appeal feels the need to say, okay, you made a
他把每张5美元的价格让步到了1美元。我说“好”，至于我是否想要他以1美元提供的产品并不重要。我想要遵守这个规则。所以这种技巧有时被称为“拒绝后撤退”。鲍勃，请帮我剖析一下。这到底是怎么回事？所以这个策略是提出一个足够大的要求，人们很可能会拒绝它。然后影响者退而求其次，提出一个较小的要求，而这个诉求的对象就会觉得有必要说：“好吧，你做出了
concession, I'll make a concession in return. This happens all the time in labor negotiations, for example, where people start with very large requests and then they make concessions and what the other side is expected to do is make some sort of concession in return. In one study, Dennis Reagan at Stanford University rat an experiment similar to what happened with Bob and the Boy Scouts. He brought volunteers into the lab and asked them to rate various paintings. In reality, the paintings were not the point of the experiment. It was a lovely study, and about halfway through, he said, okay, it's time for a break. In truth, one of the subjects was a Confederate of the experiment.
让步，我也将做出让步作为回报。”这种情况在劳资谈判中经常发生，例如，人们从非常大的诉求开始，然后他们做出让步，而对方被期望做出的反应是某种形式的让步。在一项研究中，斯坦福大学的丹尼斯·里根做了一个类似于鲍勃和童子军身上发生的实验。他把志愿者带进实验室，让他们评价各种画作。实际上，这些画作并不是实验的重点。这是一项可爱的研究，在大约进行到一半时，他说：“好了，休息一下。”事实上，其中一个受试者是实验的同谋。
This person said, do you mind if I leave the room? Researcher said, no, that's fine. The Confederate left and came back with two bottles of Coca-Cola, one for himself, one for the other subject. He said, I was thirsty, I got myself a coke, I thought you might like one as well. Then the experiment begins again, and at the end, the experimenter leaves the room to go get some materials and the confederate says to the subject, I wonder if you could do me a favor. I'm selling raffle tickets. And the more I sell, the greater I will be able to get in return.
这个人说：“我能离开房间一会儿吗？”研究人员说：“行，没问题。”同谋离开了，回来时带了两瓶可口可乐，一瓶给自己，一瓶给另一个受试者。他说：“我渴了，给自己买了一瓶可乐，我想你可能也想要一瓶。”然后实验重新开始，在结束时，实验员离开房间去拿一些材料，同谋对受试者说：“我想请你帮个忙。我在卖抽奖券。我卖得越多，我能得到的回报就越大。”
And you could win whatever the prize was. I don't remember, let's say it was a big screen G. Okay. And what Reagan did was to look at how many raffle tickets people bought. Those who didn't get a Coke, there was a control condition where the Confederate left room just returned with nothing and the experiment began. But half as many tickets as those who got the Coke Cola, those who received the favor were now going to return the favor by applying twice as many of the man's raffle tickets in reciprocation. What's also striking is I think, Bob, it's not labeled explicitly as an exchange.
你可以赢得奖品，无论奖品是什么。我不记得了，假设是一台大屏幕电视吧。好吧。里根所做的是观察人们购买了多少抽奖券。那些没有得到可乐的人——有一个对照组，同谋离开房间后什么也没拿就回来了，实验随后开始——他们买的票数只有那些得到可乐的人的一半。那些接受了恩惠的人现在准备通过购买两倍数量的抽奖券来回报对方的恩惠。同样令人瞩目的是，我认为，鲍勃，它没有被明确贴上交换的标签。
I think that's partly what makes it actually so complicated. If you're selling a $5 book and I give you $5 and you give me the $5 book, we've made an exchange. It's a transaction. You've given me something that's worth $5. I've given you $5. We come out equal. But I think there's something that's happening here that's not at the level of transaction, right? Because a can of coke might not be
我认为这正是它实际上如此复杂的部分原因。如果你卖一本5美元的书，我给你5美元，你给我5美元的书，我们就完成了一次交换。这是一笔交易。你给了我价值5美元的东西。我给了你5美元。我们扯平了。但我认为这里发生的某些事情并不在交易的层面上，对吧？因为一罐可乐的成本可能并不
the same as the cost of two raffle tickets. There's something that happens in these interactions that goes beyond, if you will, the world of transaction. You're not paying for the item. You're paying for relieving the pain of violating the rule that's been inculcated in you from childhood. How you think of yourself as a citizen of the culture. A third important form of influence is something that we have touched on before and it's the idea of liking. Tell us about this idea. What is the role of liking in influence? This wouldn't come to it as a surprise to anyone that we prefer to say yes to the people
等于两张抽奖券的成本。在这些互动中发生了一些超出交易世界的事情，如果你愿意的话。你不是在为这件商品付钱。你是在为缓解违反从小就被灌输给你的规则的痛苦而付钱。你如何看待自己作为这种文化的公民。第三种重要的影响力形式是我们之前已经触及过的一个概念，那就是喜好。给我们讲讲这个概念吧。喜好在影响力中扮演什么角色？我们更愿意对我们喜欢的人
we like. What's surprising is what small techniques can be employed to produce that rapport. And there are two that the research literature highlights. One is similarity pointing to commonalities. We like people who are like us. If somebody can show us that we're similar, we like that person. There's a greater sense of rapport and we're more willing to interact with and benefit and partner with that person. The author is praised. And once again, the research is clear. Not only do we like those who are like us, we like those who do like us and say so. You know, it's so interesting. This is actually something that you learned when you
说“好”，这不会让人感到意外。令人惊讶的是，只需要很小的技巧就能建立这种融洽关系。研究文献突出了其中两点。一是相似性，即指出共同点。我们喜欢和我们相似的人。如果某人能向我们展示我们的相似之处，我们就会喜欢那个人。会有更强的融洽感，我们也更愿意与该人互动、从中受益并与之合作。二是赞美。再一次，研究结果很明确。我们不仅喜欢那些与我们相似的人，我们还喜欢那些喜欢我们并明确表达出来的人。你知道，这太有趣了。这实际上是你很多年前在与肖像摄影师共事时学到的一点，
are working with the portrait photographers all those years ago, which is you were taught, you know, when people came up, tell them that their children are beautiful, tell them that their children are well behaved, praise them, compliment them, show them that you like them. In some ways, it's exactly the same idea. It is. That's what the professionals all recognize, not by understanding the literature and behavioral science, but by recognizing what worked. Through trial and error, they found the approaches, the tactics, the practices that lent themselves to good outcomes, and so they were the ones that they trained into their trained needs. One area where it's very useful to be able to offer praise and compliments
也就是你被教导的：当人们走过来时，告诉他们他们的孩子很漂亮，告诉他们他们的孩子很乖，赞美他们，恭维他们，向他们展示你喜欢他们。在某些方面，这完全是同一个概念。是的。这就是专业人士所意识到的，他们不是通过理解文献和行为科学，而是通过认识到什么管用。通过反复试验，他们找到了能够带来好结果的方法、战术和实践，因此这些就是他们培训新人的内容。能够提供赞美和恭维非常有用
is when you are the bearer of bad news. We all have a tendency to shoot messengers who bring us bad news, unless those messengers show up with an armful of flowers. That's what once happened to Bob. He had written a book that ran into a major printing era. The first 5,000 copies had errors in the pagination was off and some of the pages the print was was lighter than the other pages and my editor called me and said I've got some bad news about this 5,000 copies. These were the ones that went to the key bookstores,
的一个领域是当你成为坏消息的传递者时。我们都有枪杀带来坏消息的信使的倾向，除非那些信使带着一臂的鲜花出现。鲍勃就曾遭遇过这种情况。他写过一本书，遇到了一次重大的印刷错误。前5000册的页码排版有误，有些页面的印刷比其他页面淡，我的编辑打电话给我说：“关于这5000册书，我有一些坏消息。这些是送给那些我们最希望为这本书写正面评价的关键书店、
to the reviewers that we most wanted to write positive things about the book. And he said, I'm sorry about this. I hate it when things like that happen to good guys like you. So he gave me a compliment of being a good guy, and here's the addition to that compliment. It was a compliment that provided me with a reputation to live up to. And what I heard myself say to him was, oh, ban, it's okay.
书评人的。”他说：“我很抱歉发生这种事。我讨厌这种事发生在像你这样的好人身上。”所以他夸奖我是个好人，而这个夸奖还有附加内容。这是一个让我必须不辜负其声誉的夸奖。我听到自己对他说：“哦，老兄，没关系。
These things happen, you know, we're all human. Instead of pounding my hand on the desk and saying, recall those 5,000 books, Reese, I became the good guy. I became the good guy. That he assigned to me. It's a great strategy for optimizing compliments. If you would like people to perform more of something that you find admirable. Let's say you have a colleague who comes to the meetings that you hold on time most of the time or comes very well prepared most of the time, or comes very well prepared, most of the time, compliment that person on that and you will see more of it,
这种事难免发生，你知道，人无完人。”我没有猛拍桌子说：“把那5000本书召回，重印！”而是，我成了那个好人。我成了他赋予我的那个好人。这是优化赞美的一个绝妙策略。如果你想让人们更多地表现出你认为值得赞赏的某种行为。假设你有一个同事，他大部分时间开会都能准时出席，或者大部分时间都做了充分的准备，或者大部分时间都准备得非常充分，称赞该同事的这一点，你会看到他更多地这样做，
because you've given that person a reputation to live up to. You can use the influence technique of liking to get people to endorse various things. In one experiment, researchers use the technique to get people to endorse various things. In one experiment, researchers used the technique to get people to support an important scientific idea. Charles Darwin's Theory of Evolution. The volunteers were told about a book on evolution. And they were told that a esteemed biologist at a prestigious university had written a positive comment about the book
因为你赋予了那个人一个需要去维系的名声。你可以利用喜好的影响力技巧来让人支持各种事情。在一个实验中，研究人员使用这种技巧来让人支持各种事情。在一个实验中，研究人员使用该技巧让人们支持一个重要的科学观点：查尔斯·达尔文的进化论。志愿者被告知了一本关于进化的书。他们被告知，一所名牌大学的一位受人尊敬的生物学家对这本书发表了正面评论，
that had no effect on their belief, these people's belief in the wisdom of evolutionary thought. What if they were told that George Clooney wrote a positive comment. It had a significant impact on their belief in evolutionary. Why did the researchers choose George Clooney? They asked people to rate a whole range of celebrities and the one who was most likeable at the time, the one that was most light, was Cloney, and they just associate Cloney's favorability to evolutionary thought, and people came along. I'm blanking on who said this, but the quote was, you will never reason a man out of a position he wasn't reasoned into in the first place. And that's what we try to do very often as science communicators. We try to reason people into change on dimensions that were not about rationality. They were about belief or affect or something other than
但这并没有影响他们对进化思想智慧的信念。如果他们被告知乔治·克鲁尼写了正面评论呢？这显著影响了他们对进化论的信念。为什么研究人员会选择乔治·克鲁尼？他们让人们对一大批名人进行评分，当时最讨人喜欢、最受喜爱的名人是克鲁尼，他们只是将克鲁尼的好感度与进化论联系起来，人们就顺从了。我记不清是谁说的了，但那句名言是：“你永远无法用理性说服一个人放弃他原本并非通过理性得出的立场。”而这正是我们作为科学传播者经常试图做的事情。我们试图通过与理性无关的维度来说服人们做出改变。它们关乎信仰、情感或除
cogitation. And we make the mistake too often in the world of scholarship to use what we think is powerful to change people who didn't get there by virtue of facts or reason. It's useful to think of these strategies for persuasion in the context of battles to convince people around the world about the benefits of vaccinations and other public health campaigns. So often, scientists resort to making arguments to convince people. Have you noticed how none of Bob Chaldeini's techniques for persuasion involve hammering at your opponents using PowerPoint decks, op-ed articles, or peer-reviewed papers? When we come back, how these techniques of influence can be used for good and for evil. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantu.
思考之外的其他东西。我们在学术界犯的错误太频繁了，那就是试图用我们认为强大的东西去改变那些并非凭借事实或理性得出结论的人。思考这些说服策略，在世界各地关于说服人们接受疫苗接种和其他公共健康运动益处的争论背景下是很有用的。通常情况下，科学家们诉诸于提出论点来试图说服人们。你有没有注意到，鲍勃·恰尔迪尼的所有说服技巧中，没有一个涉及用PPT演示文稿、社论文章或同行评审论文来痛击你的对手？当我们回来时，我们将探讨这些影响力技巧如何被用于行善和作恶。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。
Psychologist Bob Chaldeeni has spent decades studying the science of influence. His book, Influence, the Psychology of Persuasion, lays out several techniques that he learned undercover while attending trainings for salespeople, fundraisers, and recruiters. So far, we've looked at three of them. We are influenced by the people we like, by our desire to reciprocate favors, and by the experience of scarcity. Like all techniques involving psychological influence, these techniques can be used for good and they can be used for evil.
心理学家鲍勃·恰尔迪尼花了几十年时间研究影响力科学。他的书《影响力：说服的心理学》列出了他在参加销售人员、筹款人和招聘人员的培训期间卧底学到的几种技巧。到目前为止，我们已经探讨了其中三种。我们受到我们喜欢的人、我们回报恩惠的愿望以及稀缺性体验的影响。像所有涉及心理影响力的技巧一样，这些技巧既可以用于行善，也可以用于作恶。
In the hands of a demagogue, they can lead nations astray. But used wisely, they can help us wrestle with some of our most difficult challenges. Take this application of the technique of scarcity. Well let's take the problem of climate change. Not just what do we stand to gain if we move in that direction. What do we stand to lose as a culture as a species? What do we stand to lose? That's one thing we can emphasize, honestly, because what we stand to lose is truly important. Unless we act in a certain way soon, we will have some things that are not retrievable. We just can't get back from them. They will be lost. So I mean, I've seen that the bumper sticker that I'm sure you've seen,
在煽动者手中，它们会把国家引向歧途。但如果明智地使用，它们可以帮助我们应对一些最艰难的挑战。以稀缺性技巧的这种应用为例。好吧，让我们以气候变化问题为例。不仅仅是我们朝着那个方向发展能获得什么。作为一种文化、作为一个物种，我们面临着失去什么？我们会失去什么？这是我们可以诚实强调的一点，因为我们面临失去的东西确实非常重要。除非我们很快采取某种行动，否则我们将拥有一些无法挽回的东西。我们就是无法挽回它们。它们将永远消失。所以我的意思是，我看到了那个我相信你也见过的汽车保险杠贴纸，
which says, you know, there is no planet B. And in many ways, that's the same idea here, which is if we're saying that if we lose this very valuable and precious thing we have, there is no replacement, there's no substitute. Right. Exactly. Using the technique of scarcity might help us push public policy in a positive direction. We need to take care of this one precious earth, so we'll recycle or aim to cut carbon emissions. But just as easily, scarcity can be used for questionable ends. For example, Bob wants new a man who used the principle of scarcity to sell used cars.
上面写着，你知道，没有B计划。在许多方面，这与这里的理念相同，也就是说，如果我们说如果我们失去了这个非常宝贵和珍贵的东西，就没有替代品，没有替代物。对的。没错。运用稀缺性技巧可能会帮助我们将公共政策推向积极的方向。我们需要照顾好这唯一珍贵的地球，所以我们要么进行回收，要么旨在减少碳排放。但同样容易的是，稀缺性也可能被用于可疑的目的。例如，鲍勃知道一个利用稀缺性原则来卖二手车的男人。
Here's what he would do. He would buy a car from ads in the newspaper one weekend, add nothing but soap and water, advertise it for the following weekend, and sell it at a much larger price. Let's say three people would call to come and see the car that afternoon. would call to come and see the car that afternoon. Instead of doing what I would have done, schedule the first for one o'clock, the second for two, and third for three o'clock,
他是这样做的。他会在某个周末从报纸广告中买下一辆车，除了肥皂和水什么都不加，然后在接下来的周末为它做广告，并以高得多的价格将其卖掉。比方说，会有三个人打电话说那天下午要来看车。会打电话说那天下午要来看车。他没有像我会做的那样，把第一个预约在一点钟，第二个在两点，第三个在三点，
he would schedule them all for the same time. And the first person would come usually a few minutes early and start doing normal car buying behavior, you know, kicking the tires, pointing out the rust spots and dance and so on, and maybe even beginning to negotiate on the price when the second person arrived. And it changed the situation psychologically completely. This car was now a resource that the two of them were competing against one another for. He would say to the second person, with this gentleman was here before you. So would you please stand on the
他会把他们的预约时间都安排在同一时间。第一个人通常会提前几分钟到达，开始表现出正常的买车行为，你知道的，踢踢轮胎，指出生锈的地方，跳舞等等，甚至可能在第二个人到达时开始就价格进行谈判。这在心理上彻底改变了情况。这辆车现在成了一种资源，他们两个人正在为此相互竞争。他会对第二个人说：“这位先生比你先到。所以请你站在车道的另一边，等他考虑完这个。
other side of the driveway until he's finished considering this. So the first person recognizes there's this lurking new comer over there on the side of them. And he gets anxious and now the third person arrives. And the first person does one of two things. Buies the car immediately. Or just can't take all this tension egg just abruptly leaves. At which time, the second person pounced, because there's a lurking newcomer waiting for him
等他考虑完这个再说。”于是，第一个人意识到旁边潜伏着一个新来的人。他开始焦虑，这时第三个人到了。第一个人做了两件事中的一件：要么立刻买下车，要么实在承受不了这种紧张气氛，突然离开。这时，第二个人乘机扑了上去，因为旁边正潜伏着一个新人，等着他或她违背意愿。
or her to disobey. Is it always wrong to communicate a feeling of scarcity? This is where things get tricky. Think back to the TV that Bob purchased, after he was told, it was the last one available. If the salesman had not communicated that information, and another customer had snapped up the TV, Bob would have been furious with the salesman. This feels very different than a used car salesman who generates an artificial feeling of scarcity in order to manipulate buyers into making a hasty decision.
传达稀缺感总是错的吗？这就是问题变得棘手的地方。回想一下鲍勃买的那台电视机，当时售货员告诉他那是最后一台了。如果售货员没有传达这个信息，而另一个顾客抢先买走了电视，鲍勃一定会对售货员气急败坏。这与二手车销售商为了操纵买家仓促做决定而故意制造虚假的稀缺感有着本质的区别。
One rule of thumb Bob uses to decide whether the application of an influence technique is ethical or unethical is to ask whether the influencer is calling attention to something real or making up something false in a given situation. If you told your boss you had a competing job offer in order to secure a raise and you actually had a competing job offer, your inducement of scarcity in the mind of your boss would be entirely ethical. But if you told your boss you had a competing job offer and you were bluffing, that would be unethical.
鲍勃用来判断影响力技巧的应用是道德还是不道德的一个经验法则是：询问施加影响的人是在提请人们注意真实的事情，还是在特定情况下捏造虚假的事情。如果你为了争取加薪而告诉老板你手里有一个有竞争力的工作机会，并且你确实有这样的机会，那么你在老板心中引发的稀缺感完全是符合道德的。但如果你告诉老板你有竞争力的工作机会，而你其实是在虚张声势，那就是不道德的。
The same goes for personal relationships. If you are unhappy in a relationship and communicate to a partner that you are thinking of leaving, that would be appropriate. But deliberately playing hard to get or threatening to leave just to induce a feeling of scarcity and worry? If that's all it is, if it's not genuine, then it is a form of manipulation, so I would agree with you that this is ethically objectionable.
个人关系也是如此。如果你对一段关系感到不满意，并向伴侣表达你正在考虑离开，那是合乎情理的。但是，为了故意制造稀缺感和担忧，而假装难追或威胁要离开呢？如果仅仅是这样，如果不是出于真心，那么这就是一种操纵，所以我同意你的看法，这在道德上是令人反感的。
Another ethical land mine has to do with the second technique we talked about, the norm of reciprocity. One time in the early 1980s, Bob was traveling through an airport when he noticed members of a religious group greeting passengers. They would walk up to people and press a flower into their hands, this passenger in the airport somewhere, and they wouldn't take it back. And they say, no, no, no, that is our gift to you. However, if you would like to give a gift to us
另一个道德雷区与我们谈到的第二种技巧有关，即互惠规范。在20世纪80年代初的某一天，鲍勃正在机场旅行，他注意到一个宗教团体的成员在向乘客打招呼。他们会走到人们面前，把一朵花塞进他们手里，这个机场里的某个乘客，而且他们不会把花拿回去。他们会说：“不，不，不，这是我们送给您的礼物。不过，如果您想为我们社会的慈善事业
for the good works of our society, that would be greatly appreciated. And I remember watching them operate like this, and people, they weren't able to simply walk away with the flower. They felt a need to give back because they had received. The interesting thing was if I followed them, I would see that the first waste container they came to, they would throw the flower with force into the garbage because they didn't want it. They wanted to be released from violation of the rule for reciprocity. That's what they paid for. But when you think about, for example,
捐一份力，我们将不胜感激。”我记得看着他们这样运作，人们无法拿着花一走了之。因为接受了别人的东西，他们感到有必要回报。有趣的是，如果我跟着他们，我会看到他们来到第一个垃圾桶时，会用力把花扔进垃圾桶，因为他们并不想要这朵花。他们只想摆脱违反互惠规则的负罪感。这就是他们付出的代价。但是当你想到，例如，
the use of gifts in lobbying, for example, I live in Washington, DC, and I'm just a short distance from case street, the home of most of the lobbyists in the country. And they give gifts to various people. They take people out to lunch. They take them on trips. And of course, these are often no strings attached lunches or no strings attached trips. But as you point out, there are always strings attached,
比如游说活动中礼物的赠送，我住在华盛顿特区，离凯斯街很近，那里是全国大部分游说者的所在地。他们会给各种各样的人送礼物。他们请人吃午饭，带人去旅游。当然，这些通常是无附加条件的午饭或无附加条件的旅行。但正如你所指出的，总是有附加条件的，
even if there are no strings attached. And the research supports what you just said, and that is those individuals, for example, physicians who've been given gifts by pharmaceutical representatives, those politicians who've been given gifts by lobbyists, act in ways to favor the benefactor. is act in ways to favor the benefactor. But Bob says the very same rule of reciprocity can also be used in an entirely ethical way to spur people to take action against a real danger. Again, take the example of climate change. You know, I've been impressed by how the evangelical community has been moved to protecting the environment, by the message that you have been gifted this planet by God. It is your job as stewards of the
即使表面上没有附加条件。研究支持了你刚才所说的话，也就是说，那些接受了制药公司代表礼物的医生，以及那些接受了游说者礼物的政客，他们的行为往往会倾向于恩惠的给予者。这种行为就是偏袒恩惠的给予者。但鲍勃说，完全相同的互惠规则也可以以完全合乎道德的方式使用，以激励人们采取行动对抗真正的危险。再次以气候变化为例。你知道，我印象深刻的是，福音派社群如何被这样一条信息所打动去保护环境：上帝将这个星球作为礼物赐予了你们。作为大自然的管护者，你们的职责就是保护你们所接受的一切。好吧，据我所知，这是唯一一个如此成功地让那些原本不支持气候变化的福音派人士转变观念的方法，让他们感受到自己负有一种债务。现在轮到他们来照顾这份他们所接受的礼物了。鲍勃告诉我，我们有很多机会合乎道德地应用影响力科学，但这需要我们成为世界敏锐的观察者。许多情况都包含着可以被有效利用以发挥影响力力量的要素。
environment to protect what you have received. Well, that's the only thing I know that has been as so successful in turning people who are evangelical and have not supported climate change to give them the the sense that they are indebted. It's their turn now to take care of this gift that they received. Bob told me there are plenty of opportunities for us to ethically apply the science of influence, but they demand that we become careful observers of the world. Many situations contain elements that can be usefully adapted to leverage the power of influence.
在我们日常生活中，鲍勃曾有机会合乎道德地运用“喜好”这一影响力技巧来解决一个长期存在的问题。送报员卡尔，这是他的名字，他每天早上开车经过我家，把报纸扔到我的车道上。大多数时候——可以说70%的情况下——他都能把报纸扔到车道中央，这样它就不会被我两边早早开启的喷灌系统弄湿。好吧，有30%的情况下，我的报纸是湿的。所以我在想，我能做点什么呢？在每个节日期间，我的其中一份报纸里都会夹着一个写着卡尔名字的信封，那是让我放小费支票用的。
In his own life, Bob once got a chance to ethically apply the influence technique of liking to fix a longstanding problem. My home newspaper delivery person, Carl, his name is, he drives by my house every morning and throws my newspaper out onto my driveway and most of the time I would say 70% of the time. He gets it in the middle of the driveway so it doesn't get wet from my watering systems on each side that will go on early in the morning. Well, 30% of the time I have a wet newspaper. So I thought, what could I do here? And every holiday season, in one of my newspapers, there's an envelope addressed to Carl, and it's for me to put a tip in Send Him a Check.
所以我总是这么做，但在去年，我在支票上贴了一个便签，我说：“谢谢你卡尔，你工作认真，总是把报纸扔在车道中央，这样它就不会弄湿了。以前准确率是70%，现在90%的时间报纸都在车道中央。”他活出了我对他的赞美所赋予的声誉。所以这其实挺容易做到的。在下周的节目中，我们将带着更多关于说服的观点回归，并探讨涉及这些技术道德与不道德使用者的更复杂困境。
So I always do, but this past year, I had a little post it, note on the check and I said, thank you Carl for your conscientiousness in getting my newspaper in the center of the driveway so it doesn't get wet. It used to be 70%, it's now 90% of the time. It's in the center of the drive. He lived up to the reputation to the compliment I gave him. So it's fairly easy to do. In next week's episode, we return with more ideas about persuasion and more complex dilemmas involving the ethical and unethical users of these techniques.
希望你能加入我们的节目。《Hidden Brain》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里吉特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷勒、瑞恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行主编。我们今天的隐形英雄是听众兼《Hidden Brain》的支持者桑德拉·米尤奇。
I hope you will join us for that show. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Brigitte McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our Ransang hero today is listener and hidden brain supporter, Sandra Miyuchi.
桑德拉说，他最喜欢的一集节目是《注意你的嘴》（Watch Your Mouth），这期节目探讨了语言以及它如何塑造我们看待世界的方式。桑德拉说：“我是意大利人，自2015年以来我一直住在荷兰，至今仍在努力学习荷兰语。因此，听到学习一门新语言不仅是掌握词汇，更是培养一种新的思维方式，这让我感到非常受鼓舞和耳目一新。”祝你的荷兰语课一切顺利，桑德拉，
Sandra says that one of his favorite episodes of the show is Watch Your Mouth, which is a look at language and how it shapes the way we see the world. Sandra says, I am Italian and since 2015 I live in the Netherlands and still struggle learning Dutch. So it was very inspiring and refreshing hearing that learning a new language is not only taking up a vocabulary, but also a new mindset. Wishing you lots of luck with your Dutch classes, Sandro,
非常感谢你对本节目的支持。如果你觉得这一集引人深思，并且想和桑德拉一起帮助我们制作更多这样的节目，请尽你的一份力让我们继续办下去。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再说一遍，是 support.hiddenbrain.org。再次重复，是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。目前本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。本集目前尚无评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
and thanks very much for supporting the show. If you found this episode thought-provoking and you would like to join Sandro in helping us to make more episodes like this, please do your part to keep us thriving. Visit support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that Visit support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
目前本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。